[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناو
موسكو تسارع للعثور على بقايا المسيره
الامريكيه وواشنطن تؤكد وحذف معلومات
حساسه من ذاكره الطائره
عبر نفق يتبع لميليشيا حزب الله اسرائيل
تحقق في عمليه تسلل امني من الاراضي
اللبنانيه عبر نفق لحزب الله
فيضانات عارمه تجتاح مناطق الزلزال
المنكوبه جنوب تركيا 14 قتيلا حتى الان
وفرق الانقاذ تبحث عن مفقودين
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات ضخمه على مشروع قانون التقاعد في
فرنسا والشرطه باريس تصفها باليوم الخطير
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان ابدا بالسياقه التاسعه
ساشير الى ان وكاله الطاقه الذريه تقول
بان تم اختفاء 25 طن من اليورانيوم في
ليبيا بشكل يشكل خطرا اشعاعيا ومخاوف
نوويه اذا وكاله الطاقه الذريه تتحقق في
اختفاء 25 طنا من اليورانيوم الطبيعي في
ليبيا بالعوده الى التاسعه البدايه من اخر
تطورات المسيره الامريكيه التي اسقطت فوق
البحر الاسود اعلنت انها تعمل على انتشال
بقايا حطام الطائره لفحصها ودراستها مشيره
الى امتلاكها التقنيه اللازمه لذلك قبل
ذلك اعلن مسؤولون امريكيون انهم سارعوا
لحذف معلومات حساسه من ذاكره المسيره عن
بعد وذلك قبل لحظات من حادثه المواجهه مع
المقاتلات الروسيه اما البنتاجون فاعلن ان
حادثه المواجهه قد تكون غير مقصوده مشيرا
الى انها حدثت لعدم كفاءه الطيارين الروس
فيما اعتبر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
حادث المسيره كان متهورا غير امن ويجب
البدء بالتحقيقات
خطوه المسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود
كان لها طبعا تداعيات كثيره وقد تدفع
بناته الى تكثيف تواجده فوق تلك المياه
الجنرال السابق بالجيش الامريكي مارك هيرت
قال ان التصرف الروسي استفز النيتو على
راسهم الولايات المتحده واعتبر من الان
واعتبارا طبعا من الان ستشاهد موسكو
اسرابا من الطائرات ومسيرات الناتو فوق
البحر الاسود وفقا طبعا للجنرال الامريكيه
السابق مضيفا انه على روسيا ان تتحمل بعد
الان تبعات تصرفاتها المتهوره التي تسببت
باسقاط المسيره الامريكيه
قبل ذلك قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي طائرات
الروسيه قامت بممارسات غير مهنيه فوق بحر
البلطيق مشيرا الى ان روسيا عليها الواجب
بان تقوم بتشغيل طائراتها العسكريه بطرق
امنيه ومهنيه
كلمات فقط عن حلقه مزعجه امس اعلم ان
الجميع هنا سمع ان الطائرات الروسيه
انخرطت مره اخرى في ممارسات خطيره ومتهوره
وغير مهنيه يوم الثلاثاء في المجال الجوي
الدولي فوق بحر البلطيق والقى الطائرتان
روسيتان الوقود على طائره امريكيه دون
طيار من طراز ام كيوناين كانت تقوم
بعمليات روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي
وضرب الطائره الروسيه طائرتنا ام كيوناين
مما اسفر عن تحطم طائرتنا هذه الحلقه
الخطيره هي جزء من نمط من الاجراءات
العدوانيه والمحفوفه بالمخاطر وغير الامنه
من قبل الطيارين الروس في المجال الجوي
الدولي لذلك ستستمر الولايات المتحده في
الطيران والعمل حيثما يسمح القانون الدولي
ومن واجب روسيا تشغيل طائراتها العسكريه
بطريقه امنه ومهنيه
حطام القصيره الامريكيه تشغل بالروسيا
والغرب حاليا الاخيره ارسلت طائرات
امريكيه واوروبيه لمسح منطقه السقوط املا
بايجاد بقايا لتلك المسيره ولكن ما هي
هويه هذه المسيره التي اشعلت سجالا بين
القوتين العظمتين واوضحت هنا واشنطن انها
مسيره تقوم بعمليات روتينيه في المجال
الجوي الدولي المسيره هي من نوع ام كيو 9
وهي طائره استطلاع تستخدمها القوات الجويه
الامريكيه لجمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
واجراء مهام المراقبه والبحث والانقاذ
والضربات الدقيقه على اهداف عاليه القيمه
والحساسيه يمكن لهذه الطائره حمل ثمانيه
صواريخ موجهه بالليزر و16 صاروخا من طراز
هل فاير وهذا يسمح لها بالتحليق في الهواء
بمسافه تصل الى 1850 كيلومترا والطيران
على ارتفاع يصل الى 50 الف قدم ام كيو 9
ريبرت تعتبر العمود الفقري لاسطول
الاستطلاع الجوي للجيش الامريكي وتبلغ
تكلفتها حوالي 30 مليون دولار لكن
مشاهدينا ومقابل كل هذه المواصفات
والقدرات الا ان هذه المسيره تمتلك عيبا
تجعل منها هدفا جويا سهلا وعرضا مكشوفه
لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي فهذه المسيره قامت
بمهام فوق العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى طبعا ويتم تشغيلها عن بعد بواسطه
فريقين من قاعدتين من اصل 20 قاعده في
سبعه عشره ولايه
[موسيقى]
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه سرعتها تصل الى 370 كيلو مترا في
الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نحو 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن هذه الازمه بين
واشنطن وموسكو ينضم الي من موسكو عبر
سكايب بافل المحلل العسكري استاذ بابل
سابدا من التسريبات غير الرسميه عن
جنرالات امريكيين بان ما حصل سيدفع
بالولايات المتحده الى ارسال المزيد منها
هنا هناك نقطه مهمه بموضوع الحرب بان
الولايات المتحده لا تزود اوكرانيا
بالسلاح فقط وانما بالمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه التي تجمعها هل من هذا
المنطلق كان استهداف من قبل موسكو
لا استطيع ان اقول بانها هوجمت لم تسقط
بهجوم ضدها فاكهه الطرفين هناك اي استخدام
للاسلحه من قبل الطرفين
وبلاك الطرفان اتفقا على ان هنالك
او منطقه سقوطي
[موسيقى]
المسيره كانت
بالقرب من القرن وفق البحر الاسود
الامريكيون التحرش
وقالوا بان هناك طائر حلقات قريبه جدا
منها ولكن من الواضح انما حصلت هو حادثه
كلا على طرفين يتفقان على ذلك لان لا احد
يريد من هذه الحادثه باي تصعيد لتصبح شيء
اسوا ومن الواضح الان ان لن يكون هنالك
تصعيد ولكن سيكون هنالك تبادل ربما
بالبيانات او الانتقادات ولكن هذا
او هذه ليست اخره او احدث او اكثر كلفه
بين مسيره الامريكيه فهي ارخص بعشر مرات
التي اسقطت فوق الخليج العربي قبل بضعه
سنوات من قبل الايرانيين وتلك تم اسقاطها
واما هذه فاكهه مجرد حادثه
حاولوا تخفيف التوتر
ولا احد بحاجه الى وصول مراحل معقده هذه
هي الانباء الساره اما الانباء السيئه كان
هنالك طائرات اخرى تحلق هنا في البحر
النرويجي والبلطيق
وفوق البحر الاسود وكلها طائرات استطلاعيه
ومقاتلاتك وفيها طواقم في هذه الحادثه لم
يقتل احد ولكن اذا ما قتل احده في
المستقبل اذا ما حصل اي تصادم
فستكون تلك الحادثه اسوا بكثير وقد تقود
الى تصعيد حقيقي وهذا احتمال وارد
انا ما حدث مع هذه المسيره
مختلفتين بين الجانبين الروسي والامريكي
حول عمليه سقوطه ولكن الرساله منها هل هي
احترام قواعد الاشتباك الموجوده هناك بهذه
المنطقه حتى لا تتوسع الحرب بين الطرفين
ومره اخرى كانت على بعد 120 كيلو مترا عن
القرن
والقرن غير معترفه بها من قبل المجتمع
الدولي ولا حتى من قبل الولايات المتحده
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
بالاستاذ بافلجنهاور المحل العسكري من
موسكو على ما يبدو انه تفضل استاذ
اما اعلن
اعلى
هذه المنطقه محرمه على
الطيران المدني
وهي ليست فلا احد يستطيع ان يقولها هذا
التدخل او توغل امريكي فوق اراضي روسيه
ولكن يرغب بالروسي
حظ اعتبر بان تحليق قرب الحدود الروسيه
بسبب انه يعتبر هذه الاراضي الروسيه استاذ
بابل يعني بالجانب الاخر هذه الحوادث تحصل
ايضا حتى يعني بمنطقه اسخن وهي منطقه بحر
الصين ودائما تحصل هذه الحوادث ويتم يعني
تخطيها هل يمكن القول باننا تخطينا ازمه
ما حصل بالامس
هذه المره نعم واريد كلامك ولكن
ربما يحصل شيء اسوا بكثير في المستقبل
فمثلا لو كان هنالك
طائرات امريكيه او فرنسيه وبريطانيه فيها
طيارين تحرق فوق نفس المنطقه واحيانا
ترافقهم الطائرات المقاتله فربما يحصل
هنالك صدام حقيقي ويقع فيها ضحايك وهذا
كما ذكرت حصل في شرق الصين فاحنا كصدامات
الاستطلاع الامريكيه ومقاتله صينيه
وفقدت الطائره الصينيه والطيار مات ولم
يعثر عليه
جزر وكانت تلك ازمه حقيقيه ولكنها حلت في
الختان وبذلك
اي التبادل لاطلاق النيران او خسارتي حياه
او طائره يقودها طيار قد تتسبب بوضع اسوا
بكثير من مجرد
فقدان مسيره لا تعتبر بين الاحدث والاكثر
تطورا من مسيرات الامريكيه شكرا لك استاذ
بافلجنهاور المحلل العسكري حدثتنا من
موسكو
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه ما تزال
المعارك على اشدها لحسم السيطره على مخموت
فقد اعلنت مجموعه تحقيق تقدم جديد في
المنطقه الصناعيه واضافت فاجنر انها سيطرت
على بلده في محيط بخموت وبالتالي وسعت
رقعه تطويق المدينه هذا ويحاول جيش الروسي
بس السيطره الكامله على كامل الدومباس في
وقت ما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم رغم
كل التحديات التي تواجهها بعدما اتهمت
كياف روسيا باستخدام اسلحه محرمه تحتوي
على الفوسفور الابيض في قرب
فرى الروس المناهضون لحرب بلادهم في
اوكرانيا الى ارمينيا وجورجيا التي
تتشاركان مع روسيا في التاريخ وبعد اشهر
قليله من بدء الحرب تدفق الروس الى يريفان
وتلبيسه تبليسي عفوا لبدء حياتهم من الصفر
وفق تقرير لصحيفه
ان الروس يدركون تماما ان وضعهم حساس جدا
ويحاولون السير بعنايه امام المجتمع
الجوشي والارمني فمنهم من يساهم في خدمه
المجتمعات المحليه من خلال العمل التطوعي
لتعويض عن سمعه بلادهم التي تدهورت بعد
شنها طبعا الحرب في اوكرانيا وكان لافتا
جدا ان بعض الروس في مدينه ريفان جمعوا
اموالا للاجئين الاوكرانيين للتوضيح انهم
ضد شان موسكو حربا على بلادهم
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي والشبك وشرطه
اسرائيل عن انفجار عبوه ناسفه في المنطقه
شمال اسرائيل مطلع هذا الاسبوع اسفرت عن
اصابه اسرائيل وقال البيان المشترك للجهات
الامنيه ثلاث انه تم تحديد منفذ الهجوم في
مستوطنه يعاره مشيرا الى انه كان في سياره
وتم قتله والعثور على اسلحه وحزام ناسف
بحوزتهم وحسب التحقيقات الاسرائيليه فقد
تسلل المنفذ من الاراضي اللبنانيه وانه لا
يزال التحقيق يجرى بشكل موسع على الحوله
العمليه وعن مدى تورط حزب الله فيها
الى ذلك اكدت مصادر العربيه انه يتم
التحقيق في تسلل منفذين اثنين للهجوم عبر
نفق تحت الارض يتبع لحزب الله واضافت
المصادر ان المنفذين الفلسطينيين قتل
الجيش الاسرائيلي احدهما ونجح الاخر في
العوده الى لبنان واضافت مصادر العمليه ان
اسرائيل لم تكشف النفق لفتره طويله وانه
ربما تم استخدامه لعمليات تهريب او دخول
منفذي هجمات جديده
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب ايال عليمه المحلل
العسكري استاذ سابدا من يعني اخر
الاحداثيات عن هذه العمليه هل من جديد
اعلن عن الاستخبارات او عن وزاره الدفاع
اولا من ناحيه
انه
استاذ اياد اسمح لي سانتقل الى مؤتمر
لوزاره الدفاع في البنتاجون واعود اليك
نجايف ويكيما قلت مرارا من المهم ان تكون
القوه العظمى نماذج للشفافيه والتواصل
والولايات المتحده
ستستمر بالتحليق والعمل حيثما يسمح لها
القانون الدولي
ولزاما على روسيا ان تشغل الطائراتها
العسكريه بشكل امن
لا نسمحوا لي ان اتحدث عن مجموعه الاتصال
هذه حلفائنا وشركائنا اليوم اكدوا مره
اخرى وحدتنا وعزيمتنا في دعم حرب اوكرانيا
من اجل الحريه
مره اخرى حوالي خمسين عمه من وائل حسن من
كافه انحاء العالم وكلهم يدركون بان حرب
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها من الاعتداء
الروسي حيويه وضروريه لكل من يقيم والمواد
الاساسيه لسياده الاراضي
والتحديد
الحريه وتحديد المصير انضمارينا مره اخرى
اليوم الوزير الاكسي
وياتي الى كل اجتماع اجتماعات مجموعه
اتصال برساله واضحه لخطوات التاليه في
مقاومه اوكرانيا لحمله روسيا لاحتلالها
وفي العروض التوضيحيه من هو من فريقه كلها
اوضحت الضروره الملحه لدعمنا
مجموعه اتصالها هذه دفعت جاهده لتضمن قدره
اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن نفسها من اعتداء
بوتين الامبريالين الاوكرانيون الشجعان
وقفوا بكل صلابه ضد الغزوه الروسي بصواريخ
المضاده الدبابات والطائرات والتي وفرتها
لهم دول مجموعه الاتصال تامل روسيا
بسحق اوكرانيا في حرب استنزاف لانه
اوكرانيا زودت باكثر بدعم اكثر من اربعين
دوله في هذه الاثناء
اعتمدت روسيا على ايران وكوريا الشماليه
والطرق استخدام معدات يعود تاريخها الى
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بدات تنفد منها القدرات ونفذ منها
الاصدقاء بوتون الان
لعام كامل
وادرك بانوات المتحده ودول مجموعه اتصال
ستدافع وتدعم اوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها
ولكن بوتين لا يزال يؤمن بانه يستطيع سحق
اوكرانيا فلا نستطيع ان نتخلى عنهم ولن
نفعل ذلك
وسمعت بوضوح اليوم ان اعضاء مجموعه
الاتصال يعلمون تماما اننا يجب ان نقدم له
بسرعه سريعه وكامله كافه التزاماتنا وهذا
يشمل تقديما القدرات
لساحه المعركه
وضمان الجنود الاوكرانيين يحصلون على
التدريب وقطع الغيار والصيانه التي هم
بحاجه اليها لاستخدام هذه الانظمه الجديده
في اسرع وقت وسوف نستمر بالبحث عن تبرعات
جديده واليوم
الذي حققناه وبعض التزامات كبيره جديده
السويد اعلنت انها بعشر دبابات
في ومكونات الدفاع الجوي الاساسيه النرويج
تتشارك مع الولايات المتحده للتبرع
بمنظومه نيسان الى اوكرانيا وهولندا حققت
تقدما كبيرا في المبادره بعقود جديده
لتضمنه استمرار تدفق القدرات الجديه لارض
المعركه ودون اشكر سلوفينيا على احداثي
السهاماتها والتي تساعد في تلبيه بعض
متطلبات اوكرانيا ذات الاولويه من ضمنها
المدرعات منذ اكثر من عام يعتبرات مثل هذه
من قبل اعضاء مجموعات الاتصال كانت ضروريه
لحرب اوكرانيا الدفاع عن سيادتها وقد
زودنا قدرات قتاليه هامه
ليستخدمها لاوكرانيون لردعي غزو روسيا
ولممارسه او اخي
وجعلي الامور في مصلحتهم على المعركه ولكن
لاوكرانيا تدافع عن نفسها وعن مواطنيها عن
المدى البعيد فيجيب ان نستمر في مساعينا
فسنساعد اخرى على استدامه الدبابات
والمقاتلات المدرعه
والمدرعه الاخرى التي تصل الى الخطوط
الاماميه وسوف نستمر بشكل ملح لتدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين على القدرات التي
يزودها لهم
للخطط التكتيكيه التي هم بحاجه
مناوراتهم بحاجه لها وسوف نبحث في مخزوننا
وموازناتنا لاعاده تزويد اوكرانيا طوال
العام كما سنستمر بعملنا الهام الى جانب
شركائنا الاوكرانيين المحافظه على
المسائله للمساعدات الامنيه التي نزودها
لهم واخيرا
والاهم من كل شيء سوف نبقى متحدين معا
مساعد اوكرانيا للعيش من اجل العيش بحريه
ويساعد لان نظهر بان القوانين مهمه ونساعد
في تحقيق امننا المشترك في عالم مفتوح
قائم على القوانين والحقوق شكرا جزيلا لكم
ولا نعطي الكلمه لرئيسي لكلمته
واسعدتم مساء شكرا وزير على قيادتك كما
وضعها الوزير هذه عاشره اجتماع واجتماعات
وتبرعات منها ما كانت لتنعقد لولا قياده
الوزير استون
والتوجيهاتكم تبقى ضروريه لتحقيق النجاح
المستقبل المجموعه كما اشكر الوزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
الماضي
وكذلك
كلها هؤلاء يستمرون بقياده الجيش
الاوكراني في حربهم للحريه كما اشكرك فتاه
وزراء الدفاعي ورسائل اركان
في اجتماع اليوم من ضمنهم النيتو الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بتوفير الدعم الضروري لاوكرانيا كل امه
تساهم بما تقدر عليه تضمن توافر السوق
الدفاع عن نفسها ضد هذا الغزو غير
القانوني وغير المستفز مضت حوالي 13 شهرا
منذ غاز روسيا
لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا دوله مستقله منذ عام
ولم تمثل اي تهديد باي شكل لروسيا روسيا
اطلقت وتستمر
بحربها حرب عدائيه بابتهاك صارخ للقانون
الدولي هذه
انها اعتداء روسيه ضد القانون الدولي الذي
وضع منذ 80 عاما ثمانيه عقود منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه استمعنا الى
المؤتمر المشترك لكل من وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ورئيس الاركان الامريكي والذي
شدد فيها طبعا الوزير الامريكي على ان
تحليق الطائره المسيره الامريكيه كان ضمن
الاجواء الدوليه وطبعا تجديد وتاكيد على
الدعم الامريكي لحرب اوكرانيا والوقوف الى
جانب اوكرانيا بهذه الحرب ولو طبعا الجانب
الروسي على التصرف الذي اعتبروه متهور
بعمليات الطائره المسيره بالعوده الى
موضوع التسلل عبر الحدود اللبنانيه
الفلسطينيه وعبر طبعا مع تحدثنا عنه ادخال
مقاتلين الى هناك والعمليه التي حصلت اعود
الى تل ابيب وايال عليمه المحلل العسكري
استاذ يعني كنا نتحدث عن اخر الاحداث
الاحداثيات بهذه العمليه كيف يمكن يعني
نتحدث عن نفق طويل تم بناؤه على فتره
طويله جدا اليوم اكتشف من قبل
الاسرائيليين ماذا يعني ذلك على المستوى
العسكري
اولا الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يؤكد لان عمليه
التسلل تمت عن طريق نفق على
الماليه بل يرجح ان شخصا بما فرضه تمكن من
الحدود ومن هناك التسلل الى الداخل
الاسرائيلي والوصول الى المفترق حيث وضع
العضو الناسفه وبالتالي حاول العوده شمالا
وهناك تمت تصفيته الجيش الاسرائيلي يست
بعد احتمال التسلل عن طريق السياج موجود
قائمه
خاصه لك بعض الث
غرات بعد اذا ما كان فعلا قد استخدم نف
قه
حول التفاصيل حتى الساعه لدواعي امنيه
بحسب الرسميين الاسرائيليين ولكن بموضوع
العبوه الناسفه من المعلوم حتى الساعه
بانها غير مسبوقه بالاونه الاخيره على
الساحه الفلسطينيه ومن هنا الخوف
الاسرائيلي بانها شبيهه بالعبوات التي
كانت تستخدم ضد القوات الاسرائيليه ضمن
يعني خلال حرب الجنوب ايضا ماذا يعني ذلك
على المستوى العسكري
هذا صحيح هذه العبوه التي وضعت
معروفه في الساحه الفلسطينيه وربما الجيش
الاسرائيلي قد واجه هذه العبوات في خلال
تواجده في الجنوب اللبناني من هذه الناحيه
لا شك بان الوضع العبوه والح
ادث النجاح
الشخص الذي نفذ هذه العمليه في التسلل الى
الداخل الاسرائيلي واستخدام هذه العبوه
هذا قد يكون بمثابه عامل جديده تحدي جديد
بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي خاصه ان منطقه
الحدود الشماليه تع
تبر بشكل او باخر
الحدود اللبنانيه رغم
التوتر مع حزب الله لم
حوادث من هذا
من هذه الناحيه هناك علامات استفهام اذا
ما كانت اسرائيل ربما امام واقع
هناك في هذه المرحله تقييمات مستمره
للاوضاع وربما ايضا اتخاذ التدابير
اللازمه من ناحيه خصوصا ان هناك دائما خوف
اسرائيلي من هذه الجبهه واحتماليه يعني
فتحه باي لحظه شكرا لك يا عليمه المحلل
العسكري حدثنا من تل ابيب
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تداعيات انهيار السيليكون فالي لم تنتهي
بعد الاسهم الاوروبيه تخسر نحو 30% من
قيمتها اليوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل من تركيا حيث
افادت وسائل الاعلام محليه بمقتل 14 شخصا
على الاقل نتيجه فيضانات في منطقتين
متضررتين بالزلزال في جنوب شرق تركيا كما
لقي تسعه اشخاص حتفهم في مدينه شانلي
اورفا من بينهم خمسه سوريين عثر عليهم قتل
في طبق السفلي لاحد المباني وفق وكاله
انباء الاناضول
[موسيقى]
وان مر اربعين يوما على الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا الا ان تداعياته لا
تزال مستمره لبل تتفاقم الماسي ايضا
فيضانات مدمره اجتاحت مناطق دفعت الثمن
الاكبر في زلزال وهي ولايتها شانلي اورفا
وايديامان جنوب تركيا وفقا طبعا لاداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه التي اعلنت ان
كميه الامطار الهاطله في قضاء توت بولايه
اديمان في اخر 24 ساعه بلغت 136 مليمتر في
كل متر مربع واوضحت ان الفيضانات ادت
لمصرع وفقدان عدد من الاشخاص لافته طبعا
الى استمرار عمليات البحث عن المفقودين
اما في شانلي اورفا فقد بلغ معدل هطول
الامطار الى 111
متر لكل متر مربع في اخر 24 ساعه بحسب
طبعا
هنا كذا واضافت بان الفيضانات اسفرت عن
مصرع سبعه اشخاص وعلى الاقل طبعا وفقدان
شخصين وتم اغلاق المدارس في الولايه
متسببه بدمار منازل وانجراف للسيارات
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ذلك وما زاد الامر سوءا هي البنى
التحتيه التي دمرها الزلزال في الولايتين
فمجاري الصرف الصحي والمياه تضررت بشكل
كبير مما اثار واثر سلبا على جريان مياه
الامطار وصرفها وكان زلزال مدمر قد ضرب
سوريا وتركيا مما اسفر عن مقتل نحو
55,000 شخص واجلاء حوالي مليوني شخص الى
مراكز ايواء مؤقته مثل الخيام والحاويات
والتي ما زال بعضها موجوده فيها حتى
الساعه
[موسيقى]
على الجانب الاخر من حدود الزلزال بدات
فرق الدفاع المدنيه وسلطات المحليه شمال
سوريا مرحله هدم المنازل الايه للسقوط
بفعل الزلزال الاخير وصفه مناشدات السكان
المتضررين بضروره تعويضهم ما فقدوه بعد ما
صاروا نازحين في المخيمات فلنتابع
سمحوا لابو دلوع القاء نظره اخيره قبل هدم
منزله وهو اوفر حظا من الاف العوائل التي
دمرت منازلها بشكل كامل بفعل الزلزال
الاخير الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
انكسر كمان
كان عندي تلفزيونات تنكسروا
تغيرت ملامح المدن والبلدات وسويت احياء
بالارض امتلات الجدران الصامده بعبارات
تقيم حاله كل منزل بعد بدء الدفاع المدني
مرحله جديده لرفع الانقاذ وهدم جميع
المنازل الايه التي للسقوط
بلغت الخسائر الاجماليه شمال غرب سوريا
فقط اكثر من خمسه مليارات دولار بحسب
السلطات المحليه تشمل المرحله الثانيه
ايضا ازاله الانقاض التي ضربها هذا
الزلزال وايضا ازاله انقاب المنازل التي
قيمت عبر مهندسين مختصين والتي كانت تشكل
خطرا على حياه اهلنا المدنيين لكنها حكومه
النظام السوري او المنظمات الدوليه
والمحليه لم تصدر اي تعهدات تتعلق بتعويض
العوائل التي باتت تفتقر لكل مقومات
الحياه البسيطه اللازمه لمرحله التعافي من
الكارثه
بلشنا من سنه 86
حجره ورقه حجره 10 سنين لخلصنا بناء البيت
كامل خمس سنين لخلصنا نص غرفتين وصالون
بعد بعد اربع سنين لحتى اجمعنا نحن كنا
موظفين يا ابني البيت ما بحسن صلته انا
ووضعه شايفينه حرج مزبوط ولا لا وضعه يعني
شايفينهم يحاول من قدرت لهم النجاه جمع
بقايا اشيائهم خلال هدم منازلهم علها
تساندهم في رحله نزوحهم الجديده ليضاف 240
الف شخص الى عداد النازحين في الشمال
السوري بلا حلول مؤقته او مستدامه ترك
اصحاب هذه المنازل احيائهم الى غير رجعه
بعد اخلائها وسط ششح المساعدات الدوليه
ولا وجود اي تعويضات دوليه او محليه بعد
كارثه الزلزال
مسلم سيد عيسى العربيه بلده ارمناز ريف
ادلب الشمالي
[موسيقى]
بعدما وصل وفد قضائي اوروبي للسجواب حاكم
مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه الى قصر العدل في
بيروت لم يكتمل نصاب الجلسه المقرره لان
سلامي لم يحضرها الامر الذي استدعى تاجيل
هذه الجلسه الى الخميس القادم في اطار
تحقيقات تتمحور حول ثروته وشبهات غسل
الاموال
وين بدنا نروح يجوا ياخذونا بقى يتذمر
اللبنانيون من ازمه اقتصاديه هي الاسوا في
تاريخ البلاد حلت عليهم في 2019 صنفها
البنك الدولي من بين الاسوا منذ عام
1850 وبينما يغص لبنان بازمه سيوله حاده
تبرز قضيه النصف مليار دولار ونعني بها
قضيه الرياض سلامه حاكم المصرف المركزي
المتهم بالتورط في جرائم رشوه وغسل اموال
واختلاس وتهريب وفي كل مره تتحرك القضيه
ينفي سلامه الادعاءات قائلا انها محاوله
لجعله كبش فداء بسبب الازمه الماليه في
لبنان ومن هذه البوابه كان من المقرر ان
يدخل جلسه تحقيق اوروبيه لكنه تغيب عنها
وعليه ارجات السلطات القضائيه الموعد
للخميس لكن وزاره العدل طالبت بالقبض على
حاكم المصرف المركزي وشقيقه رجا
للحديث اكثر عن المجريات القانونيه طبعا
والسياسيه لهذه القضيه ينضم الينا من
بيروت لؤي غندور المحامي والناشط السياسي
استاذ لؤي يعني بعدما ضم القاضي اليوم
مذكره الاعتراض وطبعا ضمه لاساس المطالعه
لاحقا
سيمثل على الاغلب رياض سلامه الخميس
المقبل امام القضاء هي جلسه استماع وليست
جلسه ادعاء ما المسار القانوني لها
مساء الخير في الواقع ان هي جلسه ادعاء
القاضي شربل ابو سمره ينظر في ملف احيل
اليه بموجب ورقه طلب من النيابه العامه
الاستئنافيه اي هناك ادعاء من الحق العام
اللبناني الممثل بالنيابه العامه امام
قاده التحقيق وهناك الوفد الاوروبي ايضا
الذي
كان موجودا في في لبنان بهدف الاستماع الى
رياض سلامه عملا
باتفاقيه مكافحه الفساد للامم المتحده
التي انضم اليها لبنان
سيستمع الى رياض الى رياض والقضاء
اللبناني بهذه الجلسه
الوفد اللبناني سيستمع سيحضر ويستمع الى
ما يجري ويوجه اسئله محدده مسبقا كانت
محدده في السابق عندما طلب تقدموا بطلب
المساعده لان الدوله التي يتم تقديم طلب
المساعده اليها يجب ارسال الاسئله الى
قضائها المختص قبل حضور الوفد القضائي
الخاص
بالموفد من الدوله طالبه المساعده
فالاسئله محدده مسبقا
[موسيقى]
عندما تم تقديم الطلب الى الى النيابه
العامه التمييزيه في السابق الاسئله هي
نفسها وسيتم طرحها على رياض سلامه بواسطه
القاضي اللبناني
بعد الاستماع بهذه الجلسه ممكن ان يذهب
الى الادعاء على رياض سلام مجددا وخصوصا
الفرنسي بما ان يعني ملفات رياض مفتوحه
هناك الادعاء عليه مجددا امام القضاء
الفرنسي واذا كان يعني طلب توقيفه ماذا
يعني وما طلبت به اليوم هيئه القضايا ما
يعنيه طبعا انه في حال حجز على املاك رياض
ممكن ان تعود الى الدوله
دعينا نفرق اولا بين الملاحق لقضائيه
المشاقه امام القضاء الاوروبي او عده قضاء
عده بلدان اوروبيه منها فرنسا ومنها
بلجيكا
يعني هذه الملاحقه مختلفه تماما عن ملاحقه
قضاء لبناني يعني طلب المساعده يتم بسبب
وجود ملاحقه امام قضاء اجنبي يتم طلب
المساعده من لبنان والمساعده هي تكون في
الحصول على معلومات وهذه المعلومات لا
تؤثر في سير الملاحقه امام القضاء الاجنبي
يعني اذا كان القضاء اللبناني قد ادعى ام
لا فهذا لا يعني انه يلزم القضاء الاجنبي
بشيء انما هناك توقيت الادعاء الذي تم على
رياض سلامه من قبل النيابه العامه في
لبنان جاء بعت اعتقد على ما يعني على ما
يبدو للجميع انه لانقاذ رياض سلامه من
اعطاء اي معلومات للدول الاوروبيه ليس فقط
لحمايه رياض سلامه بل لحمايه هذه المنظومه
التي يعرف رياض سلامه عنها الكثير واذا
وقع رياض سلامه كل اعضاء المنظومه يعرفون
تماما ان سيحصل ما يعرف بالدومينو افاكت
وسيؤدي ذلك الى السقوط الجميع وبالتالي
يعني تنادى الجميع وتعاونوا من اجل اجراء
ملاحقه قضائيه امام القضاء اللبناني لان
اتفاقيه مكافحه الفساد تنص في في الماده
45 على ما اذكر على ان القضاء يعني الذي
يطلب منه المساعده يستطيع عدم البوح
بمعلومات او يستطيع ارجاء طلب ارجاء
المساعده في حال وجود ملاحقه قضائيه لدى
هذه الدوله يعني لبنان يستطيع ارجاء طلب
المساعده في حال وجود ملاحقه في لبنان
وايضا يستطيع لبنان رفض المساعده كليا اذا
وجد ان هذه الملاحقه تمر بسيادته وهذا ما
رايناه اليوم في مذكره رياض يتحدث عن
السياده وهذا مؤشر الى انه ستتم حمايه
رياض سلامه من القضاء الاجنبي حرصا على
المنظومه وليس حرصا عليه اما بالنسبه
لحصول لبنان على الاموال من الخارج فهذا
امر الان اعتقد انه غير مطروح لان عندما
تم الحزب على هذه الاموال قامت به هيئه
القضايا هو بالمنحه القانوني في حال تم
الحجز على املاك رياض تعود الى الدوله
وهذه مطالبه منذ فتره وليست بالجديده
وبموضوع الحمايه يعني القضاء الاجنبي يدعي
على رياض ولا يحمي شكرا لك استاذ لؤي
غندور المحامي والناش السياسي حدثنا من
بيروت
[موسيقى]
بحث وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان مع المبعوث الاممي الى سوريا
مستجدات الاوضاع على الساحه السوريه
والمنطقه وقالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
على تويتر ان الامير فيصل
تبادل ايضا وجهات النظر تجاه القضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك
قال رئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين ان القوات
المسلحه الروسيه حققت نتائج ملموسه في
محاربه الارهاب الدولي بسوريا على حد
تعبير وخلال استقبال رئيس النظام السوري
بشار الاسد بموسكو اكد بوتين ان موسكو
تساعد بكل وسيله ممكنه في التخلص من تبعات
الزلزال في سوريا
نحن على تواصل دائم ونشهد تطوير علاقتنا
وبفضل جهودنا المشتركه وايضا عبر مساهمه
القوات المسلحه الروسيه تم تحقيق نتائج
ملموسه لمواجهه الارهاب الدولي وهذا يتيح
فرصه اكبر لتحقيق الاستقرار داخليا
واجتماعيا
بجانبه اكد رئيسا نظام السوري بشار الاسد
دعمه للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا معربا عن
امتنانه لمواقف موسكو في دمشق بالرغم من
خوضها حربا مع كييف
نا ثابت في دعم الموقف السوري من هذه
الحرب ضد النازيه القديمه الجديده واقول
قديمه جديده لان هذه النازيه دعمتها دعمها
الغرب قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه واحتضن
قادتها بعد الحرب والان هو يستمر في دعمه
كما كان سابقا واود ان اقول امتنان الشعب
السوري لكم ولي الحكومه الروسيه للمواقف
الثابته تجاه الحرب في سوريا رغم ان روسيا
هي اليوم في حاله حرب
[موسيقى]
منيت الاسواق الاوروبيه وعلى راسها اسهم
قطاع البنوك بخسائر فحاده في جلسه اليوم
لتستمر حاله الهلع التي اصابت الاسواق بعد
تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه خلال ايام قليله
ونتيجه للتراجعات الحاده تم ايقاف التداول
لفتره وجيزه على اسهم اكبر بنوك الاوروبيه
في وقت تجاوزت خسائر بعض الاسهم نسبه
الثلاثين بالمئه
نظر مشاهدينا على اسهم البنوك الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد تعليق امر اعتقاله عمران خان يقول ان
الحكومه تسعى لابعاده عن المشهد السياسي
لتزوير الانتخابات القادمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد للمره الثانيه منذ يناير
الماضي يتظاهر معارضوا اصلاح نظام التقاعد
الذي طرحه الرئيس الفرنسي
وتامل النقابات ان تظهر الاحتجاجات في
جميع انحاء البلاد معارضه العمال
والموظفين الهائله لخطه رفع سن التقاعد من
اثنين وستين عاما الى اربعه وستين عاما في
حين يحاول برلمانيون ايجاد تسويه بشان هذا
النص الذي يثير جدلا وتبدو طبعا الحكومه
مصممه على تمريره مع او بدون تصويت
[موسيقى]
اداؤها يشبه البشر تشات جي بي تي تتحدى من
جديد وتطلق نسخه جديده من تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي تعمل على تشغيل روبوت
الدردشه الشهير هي جي بي تي 4 النسخه
الجديده وستكون نموذجا رائعا تقول الشركه
للوسائط المتعدده اقل مهاره من البشر في
العديد من سيناريوهات الحياه الواقعيه
ولكنها جيده مثل البشر في اداء العديد من
المهام المهنيه والاكاديميه على سبيل
المثال يمكنها اجتياز الامتحان ليصبح
محاميا بدرجه ممتازه تتجاوز نجاح المحامين
البشر بعشره بالمئه في حين كانت النسخه
السابقه وهي جي بي تي في.5 في مستوى ادنى
وعلى عكس الاصدارات السابقه يمكن للنسخه
الجديده معالجه النص والصور كذلك ومع ذلك
فانها حاليا
تولد النصوص فقط وستكون متاحه على تشات جي
بي تي لكن من دون امكانيه تزويدها بالصور
في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر زوم من الرياض
عبدالله السبع الباحث في الشؤون التقنيه
عبد الله يعني بشكل مبسط لمن لا يعرف عن
ماذا نتحدث كيف يمكن شرح ما هي هذه
التقنيه
هي خدمه تساعدك في ادائها جدا كثيره هو
نظام ذكاء اصطناعي انت قادر ترسل له اي
طلب وهو قادر انه ينفذه لدرجه انك قادر
تقول له طور لي برنامج
بلغه معينه من اللغات البرمجه ويسوي لك
اياها قادر انك تطلب منه برنامج غذائي صحي
يناسبك وقادر يعطيك برنامج غذائي وتمارين
رياضيه قادر ايضا انك تطلب منه يكتب لك
مقاله ويسوي لك اياها قادر ايضا انه انت
تقول له لخص لي مقاله ويلخص لك اياها فهو
نظام يساعدك يعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
نقدروا نقول عنه مساعد شخصي قادر انت
تعتمد عليه ويسوي شغلات جدا كثيره
حتى الواجبات يقدر
بهذه الاهل لن يكونوا سعداء ابدا عبد الله
النسخه الجديده تطورت بشكل هائل بعد اربعه
اشهر فقط من النسخه الماضيه وبالتالي
نتحدث عن سرعه مهوله كيف تطورت وكيف يمكن
ان تتطور النسخ اللاحقه
تطورها جدا مخيف مقارنه بالنسخ السابقه
كنا نظن اساسا مع اطلاق النسخه الجديده او
السابقه انهم راح ياخذون سنه الى سنه ونصف
حتى يطلقون النسخه جديده لكن التسارع
الكبير اللي صار باستخدام المنصه او
استخدام قبل اغلب الناس سرع من عمليه
اطلاق الاصدار الجديد واتوقع انه الاصدار
القادم ممكن نشوفها ما بعد الحاله اللي
ممكن نشوفها قبل نهايه السنه الحاليه
بالتسارع الرهيب لكن نقدر نقول عنه ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو جزء من حياتنا في
المستقبل لن يلغي وظائف فقط انما سيولد
وظائف اكثر من الوظائف اللي هو راح يلغيها
لدرجه انه اكثر من 40% من اطفالنا حاليا
راح يتوظفون في وظائف واحنا ما يعرفها
والسبب اذا كان الاصطناعيه انا عارف انه
في ناس يعني نقدر نقول عنها معارضين لشي
بي تي ومعارضيين لتطور الذكاء الاصطناعي
لكن نقدر نقول عنه ان حياتنا في المست قبل
راح تكون مبهره كثير جدا بسبب دخول الذكاء
الاصطناعي
جوجل واعتبروا انه الغى ثقافه كبيره اليوم
نتحدث عن مرحله جديده شكرا لك عبد الله
السابع الباحث في الشؤون التقنيه حدثنا من
الرياض
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان انه لا ينتبه اي قلق بالذهاب الى
السجن او المحاكم مشيرا الى القلق الوحيد
بانه يكمن في هذه الخطوه التي تاتي بهدف
تزوير الانتخابات من خلال ابعاده عن
المشهد السياسي
ان الذهاب الى السجن او المحاكم لا يعلقني
لانه ليس لدي ما يدعو الى القلق بشان اي
من هذه التهم قالقي الوحيد هو ان هذا
الامر يحدث لانهم يريدون تزوير الانتخابات
انهم يريدون تزوير الانتخابات بابعاد عن
الطريق اولا ثم يبتعد بعض كبار اعضاء حزب
على الطريق
[موسيقى]
خلصت محكمه هولنديه في دعوه جماعيه الى ان
الشركه الاوروبيه تابعه لشركه ميتا
استخدمت بشكل غير صحيح بيانات شخصيه
لمواطنين هولنديين في الفتره بين عامي
2010 و2020 وورد في ملخص حكم المحكمه انه
تمت معالجه المعلومات الشخصيه لاغراض
الاعلانات وهو غير مسموح به في تلك الحاله
لكن القضيه الهولنديه
بعد مرحله المطالبه انتقلت الى مرحله
المطالبه
لم تنتقل الى مرحله المطالبه باي تعويضات
اضطرت رحلات فيرجن اتلانتيك التابعه
للخطوط الجويه البريطانيه التي غادرت
جوهانسبرج الى لندن هيثروا الى تحويل خط
سيرها الى برشلونه تركه اكثر من 300 راكب
تقطعت بهم السبل لمده تسعه وعشرين ساعه
وهبطت الرحله في المطار الاسبانيه بسبب
مشكله فنيه في المحرك وبعد انتظار دام
ثماني عشره ساعه تم ارسال طائره انقاذ
لنقل المسافرين الى وجهاتهم النهائيه ولكن
هذه ايضا واجهت مشكله فنيه ولم تتمكن من
المغادره
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن مع العناوين
موسكو تسارع للعثور على بقايا المسيره
الامريكيه واشنطن تؤكد حذف معلومات حساسه
من ذاكره الطائره
عبر نفق يتبع لميليشيا حزب الله اسرائيل
تحقق في عمليه تسلل امني من الاراضي
اللبنانيه عبر نفق لحزب الله
فيضانات عارمه تجتاح مناطق الزلزال
المنكوبه جنوب تركيا 14 قتيلا حتى الان
وفلق الانقاذ تبحث عن مفقودين
احتجاجات ضخمه على مشروع قانون التقاعد في
فرنسا وشرطه باريس تصفها باليوم الخطير
ومع ختام التاسعه نكمل المشاهدين مع 360
والان الى الزميل صهيب اهل صهيب ماذا لديك
الليله اهلا بك ليال المزيد من الملفات
والزوايا عن اخبار هذه الليله في هذه
الفتره مستمره في العربيه 360 طبعا
بالاضافه الى المسيره التي اسقطتها روسيا
الرئيس الاسرائيلي يحذر من خطر حرب اهليه
في اسرائيل والوكاله الدولية للطاقه
الذريه تكشف عن اختفاء اكثر من طنين من
اليورانيوم من ليبيا
وبالتالي الوجهه هي الاساس ومن كان يعرف
اساسا انه كان هناك كل هذه الكميه من
اليورانيوم مخباه في ليبيا ولماذا تستخدم
صحيح واين ذهبت يعني اسئله كثيره
سنحاول الاجابه عليها والبحث عن اجاباتها
ربما ليس الان ولكن على مدار الفتره
المقبله شكرا لك شكرا لك